utiliza los segmentos de abajo para
crear un cuadrilátero con vértices en
los siguientes puntos bueno vamos a ver
cuáles puntos son uno es el menos 7.50
menos 750 que sería más o menos por acá
menos 7.50 verdad ahí está listo luego
el siguiente punto es el 0,65 o 6.5
sería 0 en el eje de las x es 0 y luego
hay que ir a 6 y medio hasta acá vale
luego otro punto es el 65 o bien 6.5
06.50 s 6.5 a la derecha y 0 hacia
arriba y finalmente el cuarto punto es
el 0,2 4.5 o menos 450 menos 4.5 ese
punto de ahí ok entonces ya tengo un
punto en cada uno de estos puntos que me
dan a cada uno de los puntos azules
creo que ya solo tengo que cerrar el
cuadrilátero entonces le voy a hacer así
le voy a hacer así y vamos a ver si ya
está el cuadrilátero muy bien